[Música]
los abogados del tenista novak djokovic
revelaron que la extensión médica que le
fue otorgada para ingresar a australia
se debe a que contrajo hobbits 19 en
diciembre ahora la polémica se amplía a
los eventos en los que participó el
deportista en esos momentos
la variante de omicron del virus del
hobbit 19 mantiene en alerta a américa
latina' varios países se están
registrando récords de contagios pese a
que el linaje parece ser menos letal
siguen produciéndose muertes por la
enfermedad méxico superó los 300 mil
decesos
después de dos años y medio en una
prisión egipcia el activista
propalestino ramis llegó a francia fue
liberado por las autoridades de egipto
al renunciar a su ciudadanía de ese país
africano
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en australia los
abogados del tenista serbio novak
djokovic revelaron que contrajo kobe 19
el 16 de diciembre de 2021 razón para
que le otorgaran la extensión médica con
la que iba a entrar a ese país para
defender su título en el abierto de
australia ahora la polémica se hace
mayor luego de que se analizarán los
eventos públicos a los que el tenista
asistió sin importar tapabocas para el
momento en que supuestamente estaba
contagiado un tribunal australiano
decidirá el lunes si deporta djokovic
que aún permanece bajo custodia
migratoria juan pabló lucumí nos cuenta
más
sigue en vilo la situación de novak
djokovic antes que el tribunal del
circuito de australia decida si deporta
al tenista número 1 el lunes los
representantes judiciales de djokovic
argumentaron que obtuvo la exención
médica debido a un contagio por kobe 19
el 16 de diciembre australia exige una
pauta completa de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 o una excepción médica para
ingresar al país djokovic no ha
compartido su información de vacunación
pero ha sido crítico de la misma como
requisito obligatorio lo que despertó el
descontento de los australianos que
durante casi dos años vivieron un
estricto cierre total ante el mundo
melbourne una de sus ciudades más
grandes cuenta con el récord mundial de
confinamiento con más de 262 días
repartidos en seis encierros diferentes
por lo que los ciudadanos exigieron que
se confirmara si su excepción era válida
australia qué estás haciendo jesús todos
el primer ministro y todo eso que están
haciendo qué pasa con ustedes el mejor
jugador del mundo y le impide jugar para
que por ocultar información sobre su
salud
web él tiene todo el derecho nadie tiene
derecho a tener información privada
sobre la salud de alguien más sin nadie
no va de aprobarse la deportación al
deportista se le podría prohibir la
entrada a australia hasta por tres años
una semana después de la decisión del
juzgado el 17 de enero empieza al
abierto de australia para el que el
deportista se ha preparado
djokovic ha ganado 9 veces el abierto de
australia de individuales masculino
a la tenista renata voracova también se
le revocó el visado tras problemas con
su extensión y horas después abandonó el
país
américa latina se enfrenta a un rápido
descenso de contagios por kobe 19 debido
al avance de la variante de omicron
menos letal pero más contagiosa que las
anteriores varios países de la región
registran cifras récord entre los que se
destacan méxico y en donde se superó la
barrera de los 300.000 muertos por
coronavirus veamos el panorama en el
informe de rodrigo se dan
300 mil 101 decesos en mexico por kobe
19 es la cifra que alcanzó el viernes el
país latinoamericano se sitúa así como
el primero en número de muertes en la
región y el quinto en todo el mundo la
llegada de la variante omicron - mortal
pero más contagiosa dejó el viernes
imágenes de caos en el aeropuerto de
ciudad de méxico decenas de vuelos
fueron cancelados porque más de 70
pilotos y 140 tripulantes de cabina
dieron positivo por kobe 19 si no es
terrible es terrible porque te venden un
tiquete te hacen venir al aeropuerto
literalmente te hacen hacer todo lo que
lo que tendrías que hacer sabiendo y
obviamente tendrían que haber sabido que
su tripulación estaba en riesgo eco y
países como argentina uruguay o bolivia
registraron también el viernes sus picos
máximos de positivos por el virus brasil
sumó 63 mil nuevos contagios la cifra
más alta de los últimos seis meses allí
el alcalde de sao paulo anunció la
cancelación del carnaval en las calles
ante la situación sanitaria pero se
mantendrá el aforo limitado en el
sambódromo
en río de janeiro antiguas instalaciones
de los juegos olímpicos de 2016 se han
habilitado para la realización masiva de
tests de insulto hombres más no tengo
ningún síntoma pero tuve contacto con un
hijo que fue de viaje a buceo pero para
limpiar mi conciencia me hice la prueba
en facebook
en el vecino colombia el viernes se
registró también el mayor número de
casos desde el pasado 6 de julio al
mismo tiempo el gobierno redujo la
cuarentena de 14 a 7 días me parece esa
medida buena siempre y cuando ellos
incrementen la vacunación es decir
agilicen la vacunación para que el 100%
de la población colombiana esté vacunado
entretanto cuba anunció la donación a
siria de 120 mil dosis de su vacuna
abdalá que alcanza una efectividad del
92 2% según las autoridades cubanas y al
otro lado del atlántico reino unido
superó las 150 mil muertes por kobe 19
la barrera simbólica se rompió luego de
que en las últimas 24 horas se informará
de 313 nuevos fallecimientos a su vez
las autoridades sanitarias notificaron
otro récord de contagios diarios con 140
y 1390 nuevos positivos pese al pico en
los casos del comité conjunto de
vacunación e inmunización considera que
aún no es necesaria una cuarta vacuna
contra el virus ya que las actuales
dosis de refuerzos siguen aportando una
fuerte protección contra la enfermedad
grave
las autoridades egipcias liberaron al
activista egipcio palestino ramis tras
más de 900 días de detención luego de
obligarlo a renunciar a su nacionalidad
saad era cofundador del movimiento bds
pro palestino de egipto fue liberado el
6 de enero y entregado a un
representante de la autoridad palestina
en el cairo en las últimas horas llegó a
parís donde se reunió con su esposa
celina fonsat quien fue deportada de
egipto luego del arresto
y estoy muy emocionado de estar aquí
hacer los últimos dos años y medio entre
prisiones en algunos lugares de
desaparición forzada
algunos de ellos subterráneos algunos de
ellos con un gran número de personas en
un trato muy inhumano una forma de vida
muy desafiante y una gran falta de
estado de derecho o respeto por la
dignidad humana dos años y medio después
todavía tengo toda mi determinación de
continuar fin insisto en liberar a mis
amigos y a mis compañeros de las
cárceles egipcias estoy insistiendo en
los derechos humanos en egipto estoy
insistiendo en una palestina libre estoy
insistiendo en que esto continuará y no
nos detendrá con lo que pasó en otras
noticias el oficialismo y la oposición
en venezuela volverán a medir sus
fuerzas en un territorio simbólico para
la ideología chavista en medio de un
sombrío panorama económico el estado
venezolano de barinas elegirá un nuevo
gobernador para los próximos cinco años
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
elecciones clave para el oficialismo el
estado de barinas cuna del ex presidente
hugo chávez decidirá por segunda ocasión
quién llevará las riendas de este
territorio cargado con un alto
simbolismo para el gobierno los
candidatos no se den un ápice por un
lado jorge arriaza el elegido por
miraflores para disputar la gobernación
promete una mayor conexión con los
marinenses porque vamos a ver vamos a
gobernar juntos bueno me pueden dejar
solo no vamos a dejar más nunca no nos
vamos a conectar más nunca la oposición
se decantó por sergio garrido quien
batalla contra una fuerte maquinaria
electoral patrocinada por el gobierno
central
a pesar del panorama económico que rodea
venezuela las dificultades han
disminuido considerablemente durante el
proceso electoral las calles han
cambiado a una mejor apariencia y las
cosas por la gasolina se redujeron
considerablemente
ahorita también porque al gobierno le
interesa pero espera que pase unos días
pierden aunque esté yo volvemos a la
misma situación peor va a ser por
primera vez desde el año
1998 un familiar directo del fallecido
presidente chávez no ocupará el puesto
de gobernador los resultados de las
elecciones del pasado noviembre en las
que la oposición se llevó el triunfo
fueron desestimadas por el tribunal
supremo de venezuela programando un
nuevo proceso electoral que marcará
según expertos la fuerza del chavismo en
la tierra de sus fundadores y
finalizamos en el espacio porque tras
dos semanas desde su lanzamiento del
telescopio espacial james webb ya se
encuentra completamente desplegado la
última maniobra que fue realizada con
éxito fue el despliegue de su enorme
espejo principal de 65 metros james webb
es el observatorio astronómico más
grande y poderoso que jamás haya salido
del planeta buscará la luz tenue de las
primeras estrellas y galaxias agua y
otros posibles indicios de vida
llegamos al final de este informativo de
ustedes gracias por su sintonía los
invitamos a visitar nuestra web france24
puntocom para ampliar todas las noticias
[Música]